ein abend die heute plus hier nochmal im
live stream
das attentat von hanau mit zehn
ermordeten beschäftigt heute das ganze
land und die politik es ist eines der
schwersten rechtsextremistischen
anschläge oder terroranschläge in der
geschichte unseres landes und besonders
hanau steht natürlich unter schock
niemand hat das da kommen sehen niemand
hat damit gerechnet wie soll man mit
obers auch rechnen
und man muss tatsächlich sagen dass die
bundespolitik sehr schnell reagiert hat
die ist heute sofort in die stadt
gereist
innenminister seehofer ist eingetroffen
der hessische ministerpräsident volker
bouffier ist dort und auch
bundespräsident steinmeier ist schon in
hanau und alle werden jetzt auf dem
marktplatz dort erwartet zu einer
mahnwache und zu einer trauerfeier
und wir wollen dort jetzt mit euch
zusammen hin schalten dieser live-stream
ist auch dafür da dass ihr nicht ganz
alleine seid mit diesen gedanken mit den
gefühlen vielleicht mein kollege peter
wagner ist vor ort wird für uns
berichten wie es dort aussieht und wenn
ihr eben kommentare habt wenn ihr fragen
habt die wir versuchen können zu
beantworten stellt sie gerne in die
kommentare wir freuen uns wenn ihr den
stream teilt aber wie gesagt das ganze
hier ist jetzt auch ein platz um
zusammenzukommen und ganz klar
rassistische kommentare jeglicher art
werden wir sofort löschen und gegen die
nutzer vorgehen
da könnt ihr euch sicher sein so peter
wagner sie sind dort auf dem marktplatz
in hanau können sie vielleicht einen
kurzen überblick geben wie siehst du aus
wie viele menschen sind da und wo ist
die bühne wo der bundespräsident reich
stehen wird
der marktplatz ist jetzt schon voll der
aufruf des oberbürgermeisters an die
hanauer bürger möglichst zahlreich zu
kommen er war erfolgreich ich kann es
schwer schätzen
der platz ist relativ groß ich würde mal
sagen jetzt sind schon mindestens vier
bis fünftausend menschen hier
ernste mienen und man sieht 1 hanau ist
eine bunte stadt im besten sinne ein
gutes viertel der bürger von einer hat
migrationshintergrund und sowohl
menschen mit migrationshintergrund als
auch menschen ohne migrationshintergrund
versammeln sich hier gedenken der opfer
die opfer waren alle junge menschen
menschen die aus der türkei stammenden
sie wurden von dem mörder gnadenlos
rücksichtslos umgebracht
niedergeschossen in den beiden shisha
bars und hinter mir auf dieser seite ist
die bühne da soll dann gleich der
bundespräsident an kommen da wird auch
ministerpräsident bouffier war das
sprechen ich gehe mal davon aus dass
auch vertreter der religionsgemeinschaft
habe schon einige gesehen hier daran
teilnehmen und das ziel ist ganz einfach
dass hier auf dem marktplatz der stadt
hanau alle bürger zusammenstehen dass
die wunden die heute aufgerissen wurden
zumindest gepflegt werden und dass man
sich gegenseitig bei steht können sie in
etwa abschätzen wie viele menschen dort
jetzt vor ort sind ich kann jetzt auf
dem bild vielleicht einige hundert
erkennen aber der marktplatz wird eher
grösser sein
ja der marktplatz hat grob geschätzt
würde ich sagen
100 x 100 meter und ist schon ziemlich
voll also grob geschätzte ohne dass ich
da jetzt wirklich eine sichere zahl
sagen kann 5000 sind es bestimmt und es
wird immer mehr die leute strömen hier
von allen seiten her und werden an
dieser trauerfeier an dieser mahnwache
teilnehmen und sich auch danach noch
zusammen stehen vielleicht kann der
kollege hier mal einen kurzen schwenk
machen nach links oder rechts mit der
kamera das ein bisschen schauen können
ja max kannst du mal so ein bisschen
leicht schwenken dass man sehen kann was
hier so los ist ich hoffe es ist hell
genug ja das kann man mit ihr die
ausdehnung des platzes auf der einen
seite und wenn man mal auf die andere
seite nach links schwenken sieht man die
bühne hinter der bühne das denkmal für
die brüder grimm ist ja eine sogenannte
märchenstadt und hinter dem denkmal der
brüder grimm ist das rathaus verhüllt
hier
wird gerade renoviert also es ist schon
eine eindrucksvolle kulisse eine stadt
steht hier zusammen und versucht diesen
schrecklichen rechtsextremistischen
terrorakt diesen fürchterlichen mord
oder diese fürchterlichen morde
gemeinsam zu bewältigen konnten sie mit
anwesenden vor ort sprechen haben sie
damals ein bisschen rum gehört wie die
stimmung ist wie es den leuten jetzt
geht also ich habe über den tag über
natürlich immer wieder mit menschen
gesprochen und was man hört was man auch
sieht was man erkennt die menschen sind
entsetzt sie sind fassungslos sind
traurig sie sind auch wütend sie fallen
sich in die arme in dem kleinen hotel
das neben dem ersten tatort ist habe ich
mitbekommen wie die dame an der
rezeption einen anruf bekommen und dann
in tränen ausgebrochen ist weil offenbar
der sohn einer engen freundin kommen aus
dem kosovo auch unter den opfern ist und
sie konnte dann wirklich nicht mehr an
sich halten und solche szenen hier
erlebt man über den ganzen tag also
es ist einfach eine gedrückte stimmung
eine schockstarre die sich hier über die
gesamte stadt und ihre bürger gelegt hat
so während sie darauf warten dass der
bundespräsident aufs podium tritt und
mit der trauerfeier mit der mahnwache
quasi offiziell beginnt gucken wir mal
in die kommentare also ich habe hier auf
facebook natürlich beileidsbekundungen
von linda breitlauch von marie lena
euphorie sagt beileid an alle
angehörigen anna-lena schreibt meine
gedanken sind bei den angehörigen und
den verletzten verona ist scheinbar
jemand mit einem türkischen hintergrund
der kritisiert aber auch einige medien
haben auch dazu beigetragen dass
rassisten anschläge ausüben ausüben
dürfen
elf junge morden elf junge menschen
ermordet das ist einfach unfassbar
man denkt man lukas schreibt hier die
welt blieb für einen augenblick stehen
und danach war nichts mehr wie es mal
war
den menschen mein aufrichtiges beileid
und ganz viel kraft warum bringen
menschen so viel leid also auch hier bei
uns in den kommentaren viel
fassungslosigkeit über die tat aber
natürlich auch diese frage nach der
verantwortung der medien peter wagner
wie sehen sie das denn ich kannte das
ehrlich gesagt schwer nachvollziehen
ich glaube wenn man hier nach
verantwortung fragt muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein verantwortung trägt
natürlich in aller erster linie der
täter und nach dem wenigen was wir
bisher wissen nachdem was ich in dem
doch würden und kein manifest gelesen
habe dass er vor seiner tat offenbar ins
netz gestellt hat und auch auf youtube
gestellt hatte muss man davon ausgehen
dass er einerseits wirklich übel dass
rechtsextremistisches rassistisches
gedankengut pflegte aber auf der anderen
seite auch vermutlich ein psychisch
auffälliger wenn ich sogar kranker
mensch wahr er schreibt da unter anderem
davon dass er schon als baby von
geheimdiensten gesteuert und verfolgt
worden sei insofern die verantwortung
der medien
für diese schreckliche tat vermag ich
wirklich nicht zu erkennen
vielleicht müsste sich der user der das
meint immer genauer erklären
also vielleicht max uns noch mal ganz
konkret schreiben was du damit meinst
ich weiß dass das aus der migrantischen
community immer wieder vorwürfe gibt die
sagen es wird quasi unterbewusst dazu
beigetragen dass so etwas passieren kann
dass die hatten in der redaktion heute
auch eine diskussion zum beispiel peter
wagner hat auch über kurzen zur info für
sie ob man fremdenfeindlichkeit oder
einen fremdenfeindlichen anschlag ob man
das so formulieren sollte und wir haben
es dann darauf geeinigt dass eben nicht
mehr so zu nennen weil das quasi so
dieses gedanken bild des täters nicht
rein weil im grunde sind dass er keine
fremden gewesen die dort gestorben sind
sondern hanauer bürger ja genau ich habe
heute auch als ich hier stimmen
gesammelt habe mit der kamera einen
älteren herrn getroffen der sagte das
ist das schlimmste was er erlebt hat
seit dem krieg als hanna auch nahezu
komplett zerstört zerstört wurde und er
sagt das ist doch schon so lange eine so
bunte stadt und viele seiner bekannten
haben freunde und es ging gar nicht
darum sind das menschen mit
migrationshintergrund kommen den der
ersten generation oder schon seit zwei
generationen aus hanau
er sagt das hat doch hier so gut
funktioniert und er konnte absolut nicht
verstehen was passiert ist und fand das
auch schrecklich das war ein älterer
herr um die 70 wäre das auch wirklich
ernst gemeint hat und auch eine zeit war
mit den tränen als er mir das erzählt
hat völlig entsetzt darüber was in
dieser stadt passieren konnte ja ich
habe ja auch einen kommentar gerade auf
youtube gesehen vom user entschuldigung
astra de vielleicht wird er mal kurz auf
meinem bildschirm schalten
er schreibt ich werde keinen fuß mehr
vor die tür setzen also wirklich da
greift dieser diese terror logik dass
jemand tatsächlich angst hat sich es
draußen zu bewegen
peter wagner haben sie solche stimmen
auch gehört von menschen die jetzt
sagten ich mag mich nicht mehr offen
zeigen als muslime oder ich habe angst
hier vor die tür zu gehen
das habe ich nicht gehört ich habe
natürlich gehört dass viele die hier in
heute gesprochen haben dass sie angst
haben und entsetzt über das was
passieren konnte
aber man sieht auch diese gemeinschaft
die sagt wir stehen jetzt zusammen wir
wollen verhindern dass so etwas noch mal
passiert und weil diese angst einfach da
ist nach diesem schrecklichen morgen
gestern haben sowohl innenminister
seehofer als auch
ministerpräsident bouffier und der
hanauer oberbürgermeister heute nochmal
deutlich gesagt wir werden dagegen etwas
um ihr müsst keine angst haben dass kann
ich sein dass einzelne gruppen in der
bevölkerung hier angst haben müssen und
ich glaube das gilt auch für die weit
überwiegende mehrheit aller hier
das ist eine schwerwiegende tat ein
wirklich schlimmes verbrechen und dieser
mensch auch wenn er sich auf
rassistische so ein
rechtsextremistisches gedankengut beruft
scheint mir aber auch ein besonderer
fall zu sein
ich habe das vorher erwähnt mit wirklich
auch hochgradig psychisch auffälligen
dingen die hände an seinem manifest
veröffentlicht hat für alle die jetzt
gerade erst dazu schalten wir warten
derzeit darauf dass die veranstaltung
hier bei meinem kollegen peter ward nach
rechts als die bühne von ihnen aus zu
sehen ist los geht bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer ist vor ort der hessische
innenminister volker bouffier und der
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
der ministerpräsident der
ministerpräsident entschuldigung
also frank walter steinmeier ist auch da
der bundespräsident und wir warten
darauf hin dass losgeht und für alle die
jetzt noch nicht ganz genau wissen was
da stand der ermittlungen wie sie es
gerade aus für die hat isabel de la vega
ein kleines überblick stück gemacht
vor dem kurdischen kulturzentrum in
hanau haben sich angehörige und freunde
versammelt um der opfer des attentats zu
gedenken
alle hier sind erschüttert über die
ereignisse der letzten nacht gegen 22
uhr am heumarkt im zentrum schießt ein
mann in der shisha bar mit neid um sich
und tötet vier menschen das video eines
anwohners zeigt bilder wenige minuten
nach der tat da war der täter offenbar
schon weitergefahren in richtung westen
zum kurt schumacher platz im stadtteil
kesselstadt er betritt dort einen kiosk
und schießt wieder um sich fünf menschen
sterben hier den kioskbesitzer bot sich
ein bild des schreckens
ich habe gesehen fünf sechs leute liegen
auf dem boden zwei hinter der theke 2
also alles total blutbad war mein neffe
beraterinnen mitarbeiter arbeiteten alle
tot
der attentäter fährt dann weiter zu
seiner wohnung in der nähe
die polizei nimmt die spur auf und
findet nachdem sie die tür aufbricht
zwei leichen die des mutmaßlichen täters
und die seiner mutter
bald wird auch offiziell bestätigt dass
es sich um ein attentat mit
rechtsextremistischem hintergrund
handelt auf einem video im netz ist laut
sicherheitskreisen der täter tobias r zu
sehen der 43-jährige ist nicht
polizeibekannt besaß als sportschütze
eine waffe und es gibt auch ein
bekennerschreiben und eine video
botschaft die neben wirren gedanken und
abstrusen verschwörungstheorien aber
eine zutiefst rassistische gesinnung
aufweisen
die opfer sind vor allem junge männer
mehrere davon kurden alle haben einen
migrationshintergrund das muss ich sagen
macht mir wirklich sorgen das
gesellschaftliche politische klima klima
in deutschland ist sehr beängstigend und
ich fühle mich an ich als deutsche mit
einer migrations biografie nicht
wirklich wohl
und so wird das attentat über hanau
hinaus für politische diskussionen
sorgen
so und in hanau ist die trauerfeier
mahnwache jetzt gestartet peter wagner
ist für uns für euch glaubt der
bürgermeister claus kaminsky edeka das
ist richtig ja ich kenne zumindest eine
stimme die trauerfeier die mahnwache
gegen los und ich denke am besten hören
wir jetzt alle rein was auch gesprochen
und was gesagt wird und wie die worte
auch wirken ein großartiges ein
wichtiges zeichen für die familien aber
auch für unsere stadtgesellschaft das
heute abend hier
der bundespräsident der bundesrepublik
deutschland dr frank walter steinmeier
bei uns ist herzlich willkommen und
vielen vielen dank dafür ich darf ihnen
auch die grüße und die solidarität und
die nächstenliebe der bundeskanzlerin
dem ich heute angerufen hat hier heute
abend vermitteln
auch sie steht an unserer seite und es
ist auch eine ein besonders wichtiges
und richtiges signal dass der
ministerpräsident unseres bundeslandes
hessen volker bouffier heute auch heute
abend hier bei uns ist auch hierfür ein
herzliches dankeschön
das was wir erleben mussten
und was insbesondere die angehörigen
tief im harz tief in ihrer seele trifft
und sie schmerzt und wo wir auch nur
sehr sehr begrenzt in der lage sind
trost zu spenden
das was wir dort erleben mussten trifft
nicht nur die opfer sondern es soll
treffen und es trifft unsere ganze
stadtgesellschaft und es trifft unsere
gesellschaft in der wir leben und ein
signal will ich allerdings auch klar aus
senden diese brüder grimm stadt hanau
ist stolz darauf dass sie seit
jahrhunderten immer wieder menschen
unterschiedlichen glaubens
unterschiedlicher kultureller nationaler
herkunft miteinander integriert und ein
friedliches beisammensein und ein
friedliches miteinander
tag für tag leben und
und dass sie alle dass sie alle da sind
soll all denen die mit verehrten
gedanken unterwegs sind zeigen rassismus
hass gegen mitmenschen hat keine zukunft
und wir sind mehr
[Applaus]
und wir stellen uns denen als überzeugte
demokraten entgegen
ich danke ihnen sehr für die
aufmerksamkeit und danke ihnen ganz ganz
herzlich dass sie heute alle heute abend
alle hier sind spricht jetzt der
ministerpräsident dankeschön sekretär
bundesprogramms zur liebe mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger
das ist ein tag des schreckens
das ist ein tag des grauens und es ist
etwas geschehen was eigentlich unfassbar
ist die dimension dessen was widerfahren
ist den opfern den verletzten ihren
angehörigen ist so außergewöhnlich
das ist schwer fällt jetzt richtig und
angemessen zu reagieren
manchmal gibt es situationen im leben da
verspringt ist einem die sprache
da ist man fassungslos und ich möchte
ihnen heute sagen wir sind alle gekommen
um ihnen zu zeigen dass gerade in einer
solchen situation wir zusammenstehen
müssen dass wir uns aus respekt vor den
opfern verneigen dass wir den
angehörigen zeigen dass sie nicht
alleine sind dass die menschen im ganzen
land mit ihnen trauern sie selbst wird
lange brauchen um überhaupt wieder tritt
fassen zu können
aber es möge sie ermutigen das richten
heute abend zu viele menschen gekommen
sind sondern dass wir aus fast der
ganzen welt grußbotschaften bekommen
haben
die an hannover denken
die an die menschen denken die opfer
geworden sind und gerade jetzt müssen
wir zusammenstehen und ich möchte ihnen
zurufen
ich kann mir vorstellen was jetzt in
menschen vorgeht
die darüber nachdenken die vielleicht in
unser land gekommen sind
mit einer anderen herkunft mit einem
anderen glauben mit einem anderen
aussehen dieses verbrechen das nach
allem was wir jetzt wissen unter anderem
rassistischen wahnvorstellungen folgte
muss menschen angst machen und ich
möchte allen sagen wir müssen alles tun
damit alle in diesem land ohne angst
leben können
wir lassen uns nicht spalten
wir gehören zusammen
auch und gerade in einer so
schrecklichen stunde und deshalb werden
wir alles tun denen entgegenzutreten
sie glauben dass sie durch hass durch
hätte durch ausgrenzung und sogar durch
gewalt die gesellschaft verändern können
wir werden denen nicht weichen
nicht nur heute in hannover und nicht
nur heute sondern das was gelten muss
ist wir halten zusammen und all
diejenigen die glauben dass sie uns
auseinander bringen können denen sagen
wir wir werden keinen millimeter
preisgeben dieser freiheitlichen
demokratie nicht nur heute nicht nur in
hanau sondern immer und überall ich dann
gehen
herr ministerpräsident herr
oberbürgermeister
liebe bürger und bürgerinnen aus hanau
verehrte trauernde
ich stehe hier vor ihnen als
bundespräsident als bürger dieses landes
als mensch der wie sie und wir alle an
diesem abend um worte ringt was
geschehen ist was hier heute nach den
hanau geschehen ist
das macht uns fassungslos
das macht uns traurig und es macht uns
zornig was geschehen ist das ist
furchtbar den geschehen ist was wir alle
doch zutiefst fürchten geliebten
menschen zu verlieren nämlich nichts
kann uns den schmerz um sie nehmen
nichts kann diese sinnlose tat erklären
und nichts wird sie ungeschehen machen
können
viele die heute abend hier sind sind
voller trauer sind ratlos fühlen sich
allein gelassen
aber gerade deshalb meine damen und
herren tut es gut hier zu sein
an diesem ort sich zu versammeln
in aller stille und gemeinsam zu trauern
in dieser stunde hier auf dem platz
spüren wir dass wir nicht allein sind
und wir sagen dass wissend dass sich in
mehr als 50 städten heute abend in
deutschland zur gleichen stunde etwa ab
18 uhr tausende vermutlich zehntausende
menschen zu mahnwachen zusammengefunden
und der opfer von hanau gedenken wir
spüren meine damen und herren liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger dass es
diese gemeinschaft gibt die entsetzen
und wut teilt aber eben auch trauer
anteilnahme und solidarität zeigt eine
gemeinschaft der ihm die wir miteinander
alle brauchen die jede gesellschaft
braucht eine gemeinschaft die
zusammenhält
zehn menschen sind aus unserer mitte
gerissen und ihr tod ist ein brutale akt
terroristische gewalt hat eine terrortat
die uns auch in schrecklicher weise an
den mord an walter lippe und zuletzt an
den anschlag auf die synagoge in halle
erinnert denn das heißt doch terror
durch gewalt und tod schrecken
verbreiten angst machen uns auseinander
zu treiben
und heute ist die stunde in der wir
zeigen müssen wir stehen als
gesellschaft zusammen wir lassen uns
nicht einschüchtern
wir laufen nicht auseinander wir trauern
[Musik]
wir trauern wir neben den anteil und wir
sehen dass wir eins sind in unserer
trauer und einig gegen hass rassismus
und gewalt ich stehe an der seite der
menschen die von hass und gewalt bedroht
sind und wir gemeinsam wir stehen seite
an seite mit einander gegen gewalt und
gegen eine sprache der ausgrenzung und
herabwürdigung die doch der gewalt allzu
häufig den weg bereitet meine damen und
herren
meine damen und herren auch das muss in
einer solchen stunde gesagt sein
nehmen wir die verantwortung an die uns
alle trifft achten wir auf unsere
sprache in der politik in den medien und
überall in der gesellschaft halten wir
dagegen den einzelnen oder minderheiten
die würde in unserem land genommen wird
herr oberbürgermeister liebe mitbürger
und mitbürger hier aus hanau was
geschehen ist
das schlägt eine tiefe wunde in diese
stadt eine wunde die nur heilen wird
wenn wir gemeinsamkeit nicht nur in der
stunde des schreckens zeigen sondern
auch an den tagen die kommen und darf
dauert zeigen wenn wir zeichen setzen
der rücksichtnahme und der solidarität
setzen zeichen die den angehörigen die
um die toten trauern kraft und beistand
geben
rücksichtnahme und solidarität aber auch
die wir als gesellschaft brauchen wenn
wir zusammenhalt in unserem lande
bewahren wollen
darum bitte ich sie meine damen und
herren im angesicht des grauens sollte
und in dieser schweren stunde der trauer
zeigen sie rücksichtnahme zeigen sie
solidarität wir stehen zusammen wir
halten zusammen wir wollen zusammen
leben und wir zeigen es wieder und
wieder das ist das stärkste mittel gegen
den hass vielen dank
[Applaus]
das waren die worte von den
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier und dem hessischen
ministerpräsidenten volker bouffier sie
stehen es dann auch auf der bühne halten
kerzen in den händen man hat auch gehört
die stimmung auf dem marktplatz ist
emotional aufgeladen es gab immer wieder
zwischenrufe
ich konnte nicht genau hören was da
gerufen wurde aber die menschen sind aus
nachvollziehbaren gründen teilweise sehr
emotional wütend und in tiefer trauer
wir schwenken da erst gerade nochmal auf
die anwesenden auf dem marktplatz der
marktplatz scheint wirklich sehr voll zu
sein unser kollege peter wagner hat
gerade einmal gesagt schätzt vier bis
fünftausend menschen das können wir
jetzt von hier aus nicht verifizieren
alle die jetzt gerade erst zu schalten
oder nicht alles mitgehört haben ich
kann mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen ich
habe ein bisschen mitgeschrieben
was die einzelnen politiker gesagt haben
und dann schauen wir auch gerne nochmal
in die kommentare
schreibt mir wie es euch geht was ihr
denkt was wir fühlt weil das ist jetzt
hier auch natürlich eine gelegenheit
sich mal auszutauschen und eben auch zu
merken dass wir nicht alleine sind in
dieser situation das war so quasi eine
wichtige botschaft sowohl von volker
bouffier als auch von frank-walter
steinmeier dass wir zusammenstehen
müssen dass wir uns nicht auseinander
treiben lassen als freiheitlich
demokratische gesellschaft bouffier hat
angefangen ziemlich emotional hat gesagt
es gibt situationen im leben da
verschlägt es einem die sprache darf man
fassungslos man hat gemerkt dass wir um
die worte wirklich gerungen hat er hat
gesagt er wolle sich verneigen aus
respekt vor den opfern und auch den
angehörigen zeigen dass sie nicht
alleine sind müssen zusammenstehen hat
er gesagt und er hat vor allem betont
dass wir und auch die politik alles tun
muss damit menschen in diesem land ohne
angst leben können denn so ein anschlag
ist natürlich auch dazu da um angst zu
machen hier sehen wir noch ein paar
schilder jetzt rassismus tötet kann ich
darauf lesen nsu mord gleich das kann
ich leider nicht lesen was da steht hier
sind fahnen zu sehen die gegen rassismus
und hass eintreten das ist ein bekanntes
motiv hier die beiden menschen die sich
die hände reichen ist gucken bei der
kollege versuchte auch ein paar bilder
einzufangen die bühne leert sich so
langsam noch mal kurz zu den worten von
bouffier hat gesagt wir werden nicht
weichen wir werden keinen millimeter
preisgeben dieser freiheitlichen
demokratie und ähnlich hat sich auch
steinmeier geäußert er hat natürlich
auch mit gefühl geäußert da gesagt
nichts kann den schmerz nehmen gerade
von den menschen die einen angehörigen
verloren haben letzte nacht aber er hat
betont wie wichtig es ist dass wir jetzt
hier zusammen stehen oder dass diese
mahnwachen überall gibt in 50 städten in
ganz deutschland und ich glaube die
stärksten worte war seine aufforderung
am ende hat gesagt zeigen sie
rücksichtsnahme zeigen sie solidarität
wir stehen zusammen wir halten zusammen
und wir wollen zusammen leben wird
zeugnis wieder und wieder das ist das
stärkste mittel gegen hass so ich gucke
es nochmal in die kommentare was ihr so
geschrieben habt kommt nochmal was die
kollegen mir so rein gepostet haben
hier gibt es kommentare europa die sie
meinen deutschland ist
ausländerfeindlich und saß er meint man
muss gegen den rassismus mehr
unternehmen
ich gehe mal tatsächlich in den youtube
stream hier wo ist er denn
nee da nicht probieren denn versteckt
gehabt
soeben hatte ich ihnen noch noch da da
ist der youtube stream okay gibt aber
auch menschen die sagen ich bin selbst
ausländer in deutschland und nach 30
jahren in deutschland kann ich sagen
deutschland ist nicht ausländerfeindlich
also auch da gibt es verschiedene
meinungen dazu roboter sie meint
deutschland ist ausländerfeindlich also
da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch
verschiedene
erlebnisse so was natürlich völliger
unsinn
shisha bars verbieten dass das einfach
so ein quatsch den kann man gleich mal
ausblenden weil sowas brauchen wir
wirklich überhaupt nicht auch solche
kommentare schmeiße ich einfach sofort
raus und das ist ganz klar hassrede das
melden wir jetzt einfach mal schön
das heißt wir können als gesellschaft
natürlich gegen sowas vor wie wenn ihr
solche sachen findet online auf youtube
könnte ja auch einfach dagegenhalten und
solchen leuten einfach keine plattform
geben was natürlich schwierig ist so ich
guck doch mal was auf facebook los ist
bilder von kaffee gefragt wieso wird
eigentlich hans georg maßen nicht wegen
behinderung der justiz belangt
aber auch schwierige frage die
gewöhnliches nie so beantworten
auf facebook linda breitlauch schreibt
hier zudem reden die wir gerade gehört
haben es ist gut dass die politik das
hier so deutlich formuliert mehr davon
und es ist großartig dass die menschen
auf die straße gehen
so heißt ein abdullah karagounis
schreibt wieso immer auf türken ich
hätte gern eine antwort ja die antwort
kann ich dir jetzt auch nicht geben
natürlich die türkische migranten bilden
einen großen teil der migrantischen
community in deutschland von daher ist
es wahrscheinlich für menschen die nicht
differenziert denken eben weil sie nazi
denken im kopf haben am einfachsten sich
diese auszusuchen
aber natürlich ist das was was ich mich
als mensch mit türkischem hintergrund
auch fragen würde so bahar meint waffen
gehören verboten wozu braucht man
sportschützen auch das eine
nachvollziehbare frage an so einem tag
der tobias r der mutmaßliche täter
mutmaßlich können wir eigentlich fast
streichen aber juristisch ist das heißt
so war sportschütze und hat ein manifest
hinterlassen wo man sich fragen kann
warum so ein mensch natürlich noch an
waffen kommen kann also sehr passt
schreibt wir stehen zusammen vielen dank
dafür und ursula meint jeder muss sich
dem hass entgegen stellen auch sie so
nicht glaube damit machen wir es den
stream zu
danke euch fürs zuschauen ich hoffe ihr
könnt wenn ihr euch betroffen fühlt
jemanden finden mit dem wir darüber
reden könnt es gibt hilfs zentren
vielleicht möchte ich das nochmal zeigen
zum beispiel in frankfurt wenn ihr noch
mal hier auf meinem bildschirm geht gibt
es zum beispiel response die beratung
für betroffene von rechter und
rassistischer und antisemitischer gewalt
das ist ein angebot der bildungsstätte
anne frank da könnt ihr euch zum
beispiel dran wenden wenn ihr euch
alleine fühlt wenn ihr mit jemandem
reden möchte oder wenn ihr tatsächlich
von solcher gewalt betroffen seid das
ist glaube ich jetzt hier das wichtigste
wenn ihr in irgendeiner weise betroffen
seid sucht euch hilfe redet mit menschen
darüber und verzieht euch nicht einfach
denn das ist genau das was
rechtsradikale rechtsextreme und
neonazis jahr wollen
und an dieser stelle mache ich jetzt
wirklich schluss ich danke euch für das
zu sehen ich freue mich wenn den stream
vielleicht doch noch im anschluss teilt
und ich sagte bis zum nächsten live
stream und jetzt können wir auch einfach
ja in 13 minuten wenn ihr wollt rüber
schalten zum zdf im guten alten
fernseher gibt es die 19 uhr natürlich
ein schwerpunkt 1920 gibt es dann das
zdf spezial zu dem anschlag in hama und
das zdf hat auch heute abend sein
programm umgebaut eigentlich wollten wir
eine karnevalssitzung aus köln zeigen
und wir haben uns dazu entschlossen das
nicht zu tun sondern den bergdoktor zu
zeigen weil das wahrscheinlich heute
kein guter tag um sich an lustigen
scherzen im fernsehen zu vergnügen in
diesem sinne einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]